more than a 100,000 ethnic Armenians
living in kabak have fled the region
after it was recaptured by aaban only a
small fraction remain that's despite
aayan's assurances that they will be
integrated as equal citizens well Al
jazer secured exclusive access to the
deserted city of kendi Osama bin Javed
[Music]
reports if it weren't for the trot there
would be complete
silence even animals here have gone
quiet hindii which Armenians call
stanaker has been deserted nearly
everyone is gone after ethnic Armenian
leaders agreed with aeran that the
so-called state of vsak will cease to
exist and it feels everyone just got up
and
left strewn with whatever people
couldn't carry with them the Town Center
where thousands had gathered now pains
an unreal Eerie
scene the morg staff left too so even
the dead are being repatriated to
Armenia by the Red Cross we count to
keep on finding other uh people still
stranded for the time being in the city
in the
outskirts uh and therefore we have
another concern considering that rural
areas haven't been reached yet the
streets are completely empty all that
you can see here a scattered few
checkpoints on the entrance of Khan keni
Russian peacekeepers inside and maybe a
few soldiers here we've got the last
remaining ethnic
Armenians go gathering at a staging
point for those who still want to
leave he says this is our
city also a place where those who are
staying say
goodbye this ethnic Armenian man hugged
the first aarani he saw
[Music]
he says I want to live here with
everyone I have aarani friends who tell
me I shouldn't leave so I am staying
here the administration says it started
a registration Center provided
ambulances revamped mobile networks and
connected the city to the electric grid
but the few people Left Behind still
need Urgent
Care
if you asked me about the immediate
needs uh it's certainly uh to uh
consider yeah Power gas for the winter
coming and water now for the outskirts
and the other regions for sure uh we
have been here for decades and uh we
look forward to work with the aeran
authorities we are actually we have
always been in contact with
[Music]
them and in order to have a future
this city will need
humans to refill its empty
streets
bji
aan well we can speak now live to our
correspondent Osama bin J who is now
live in Baku was some extraordinary to
see your peace there and to see what's
happened to the city what is the future
of K kendi do you
think well according to the government
it wants people to remain who are left
it would like people who have left to
come back there is going to be a
Reconciliation process and it wants to
rebuild the city to what it calls its
former glory 30 years ago and to discuss
that further uh we have with us the
spokesman for the foreign Ministry of
aeran Mr aan haad thank you very much
for speaking to us the question remains
we're seeing witnessing scenes of Ghost
Town empty cities what really will
happen uh to this area thank you so much
for the question uh and for your
interest to get an interview with me uh
as you know for the last 30 years aan
has suffered from the occupation
Devastation and uh around 1 million
aabani population have become uh the
refugees and Ides and left this uh
region uh for with devastation and
sufferings and now as a result of the 24
hours uh anti uh terrorism uh measures
taken by aaban aaban has finally
restored its sovereignty over the
territories uh formerly called as nagor
kabak and now is kabak region of
aaban uh we witnessed uh relocation of
certain uh population of uh Armenians
from the region but I would like to note
that uh exactly around 30 years ago
aaban has left this region uh that
suffered the Devastation and casualties
uh a lot of massacres and atrocities
committed against aab Banis uh now aaban
uh has uh uh called calling to against
Armenian uh population uh to come back
uh we we are ready to embrace Armenian
uh population uh yes uh some portion of
Armenian population are still in kanand
town and other uh towns uh currently uh
uh aaban has taken sovereignty over
uh and aaban has uh uh issued a call uh
against the Armenian population uh to
come and to reintegrate uh to the aabani
society in line with the Constitution
and legislation uh of the Republic of
aaban but you see all of these promises
have been heard by people uh a lot of
people are not willing or agree to uh
believe them yet and there is a lot of
fear so what measures will the aarani
government take to to elay those fears
and like you say allow Armenians to live
side by side with aeran you know uh for
uh decades aaban and Armenians live side
by side aaban is multiethnic country
where a lot of ethnicities are living
inside aaban around 30,000 Armenians
during the conflict time lived in aaban
and now living in aaban and we believe
that reintegration and Reconciliation is
possible for that aaban has launched
dialogue with representatives of Armenia
so far three meetings were held between
the local Armenians and aabani uh
Central authorities and aaban launched
the program of reintegration that covers
uh the governance sector the economy
sector the social sector and we believe
that uh Armenians uh are uh should be a
part of this reintegration process and
within this particular uh plan uh within
the governance plan within the social
economic plan aaban is uh providing will
provide to the uh local Armenians loans
and uh social uh benef benefits to the
local Armenians to leave side by side
with the uh azanis in this particular uh
region and we believe that uh after that
uh peace and stability would Prevail in
the region and what immediate steps are
being taken we saw some ambulances in
the area we spoke to the Red Cross
workers who say they are going to be
urgent needs for the people because
there's a winter coming uh what will
immediately happen because this
reconciliation process I imagine is
going to take time uh indeed aaban has
launched uh wide areas uh of uh utility
utility building infrastructure building
uh but at the same time provides
humanitarian assistance to local
Armenians uh and uh recently uh the
medical team uh has been dispatched to
the region and now located in the H Town
hospital where they serve local
Armenians who Liv in the kand town right
now and aaban is also providing
humanitarian assistance to the local
population local Armenians and at the
same time we call on uh the Armenians
who left the region who relocated to
Armenia to return back and we are ready
to embrace them uh and we promise them
the better livelihood than they were uh
when they were the part of the military
kta established in the territories of
aaban and very quickly what will happen
now on the international front because
we've heard concerns raised by European
countries uh some other Western Powers
as well have have uh criticized aeran
for the way it handled things uh what
will happen on the international front
because you've got three separate tracks
one with the US one with Europe and one
with Russia to reconcile differences
with Armenia you know aaban uh following
the 44 Day War uh has launched uh peace
efforts and peace initiatives including
opening up the communication demarcation
of the borders but at the same time most
importantly the peace agreement with
Armenia so far uh multiple meetings were
held uh between the foreign Ministers of
aaban and Armenia but at the same time
they were facilitation efforts by the EU
commission uh uh EU council president
charl Michelle with participation of the
Germany counselor but at the same time
France president but at the same time
there were facilitation efforts by the
Russian side and the United States side
so these efforts are welcomed by aaban
but at the same time aaban initiated the
peace efforts and we believe that peace
is uh possible in the region uh with uh
the real uh backing up the respect to
the Sovereign and territorial Integrity
uh of both countries Armenia and aaban
uh and aaban is willing to continue this
effort so that uh peace would previl in
the region kabak and many parts of it
now look deserted ghost towns PE places
with without Souls how long in your
estimate will it take for people to
actually return and rebuild their lives
uh as I've mentioned uh aaban is left
this region uh in Devastation uh almost
30 years ago current aaban has launched
enormous uh campaign of reconstruction
and rebuilding of the region and there
are multiple uh projects uh I would like
to mention uh two International uh
airports have been uh established in uh
zangan uh and the fizi town of aaban
there is a building of Lin International
Airport there are huge projects
currently ongoing in the region and uh
we believe that uh uh despite the fact
that the landmine threat is still on the
ground aaban is taking a lot of measures
in order to uh local uh population
azanis and Armenians to return to leave